you want school graduated okay so you
graduated you're done the dental school
all of that [ __ ] rich in the nice
balance you know
master's in public health nice your
pears at work you're ready for video
beating your parents got money cuz
that's usually rich what am I like no
don't you get a masters in something to
make some not that much money
and white people stuff like I am
teaching and it's like hi bro
to make upgrade you could be in ninth
but I'm saying that's what you want to
do so what does it public health to do
that's one of us a me buddy I'd say I'm
in you know me I'm an engineer I am a
doctor I'm a dentist
I'm in public what make me shut up but I
don't know what happiness does anybody
yes god there's so much okay
[Music]
let's make people fight but what is what
is epidemiology your sounds made of this
book and team ecology
it is the study of epidemics
okay I'm a funny guy go get the real
answer what's the epidemiologist in the
box what do you want to do with that
MIDI me ology okay you study infectious
disease outbreaks can we be honest you
can say the same [ __ ] every time we'll
have this outbreak spread well you know
wash your hands
people are affected more you know just
everybody it's the same [ __ ] every time
every disease you ever study throughout
history just like yeah you know my looks
are dirty the poo Purell it's always a
different version to wash your hands
then put a lot of syllables and
epidemiology to make you think is some
[ __ ] muscle